bonjour et merci de réagir sur arte
france vous dénoncez un calendrier
politique expliquez nous alors en fait
il faut comprendre que cette affaire
justement qui date du 1er décembre 2018
donc dû d'élus de la crise des gilet
jaune est tout simplement enquêter elle
n'est même pas jugés celle que les les
éléments d'enquêté malgré une vidéo plus
que probante commencent seulement à
arriver donc à quelques mois de
l'échéance électorale
donc le message subliminal que les
autorités essayent de nous envoyer c'est
de nous dire vous trompez depuis
plusieurs années vous mettez en cause
l'indépendance de l'igpn
mais finalement c'était juste une
question de temps donc si la sphère du
1er décembre 2018 commencent à sortir
aujourd'hui seulement aujourd'hui c'est
à dire alors qu'on est en mai 2021 bas
tout le reste tout ce qui s'est passé
pendant toute cette crise des gilets
jaunes ce n'est qu'une question de temps
il faut s'attendre dans les mois qui
viennent à ce que ça sorte
alors que ce n'est pas du tout le cas et
j'en profite également pour souligner
justement dans l'actualité ces arguments
qui finalement nous font avaler la
couleuvre de la loi la sécurité globale
pour simplement posé la question sans
affirmation toutefois essayer de savoir
si justement c'est celle n'avait pas été
filmée à la fois par la vidéo de
surveillance et par les passants
si justement on aurait eu c'est déjà
d'une part la possibilité d'un dépôt de
plainte de la part des victimes et
également ces interpellations qui ont eu
ou en tout cas ces placements en garde à
vue qui ne sont même pas des
interpellations puisqu'elles font suite
à des convocations donc ses placements
en garde à vue qui surviennent
aujourd'hui dont je rappelle qu'il ne
s'agit que de placement en garde à vue
c'est qu'il ne débouche pas forcément
sur une comparution immédiate mais qui
peuvent justement laisser les crs
ressortir libre ou sous contrôle
judiciaire dans le meilleur des cas vous
voyez on est sur une évolution de l'
enquête qui est très très timide et sept
enlevés évolution de l' enquête
finalement on la doit à des preuves qui
ont été fournis par des passants et non
pas par les autorités ou par les
enquêteurs donc si vous voulez quand on
n'aura plus la possibilité de filmer les
policiers en action à cause de la loi
sécurité globale je doute que
à venir on est justement ne serait-ce
que les esquisses d'un espoirs de
résolution de ce type d' enquête
quatre crs avaient déjà été mises en
examen en juin 2020 pour violences
volontaires par personne dépositaire de
l'autorité publique
ce dossier devenu l'emblème des dérives
observées dans l'ensemble en face au
gilet jaune salon vous oui parce que
vous savez quand on interpelle en
général dans les forces de l'ordre on
parle de flagrant délit
donc là effectivement ces images
démontrent une certaine flagrance
justement de l'infraction
parce que j'ai consulté les atteindre au
contraire donc les déclarations de
l'avocat alors lui donc parle de la crs
43 qui faisait face à une quasi
insurrection ce qui est vrai que l'unité
était épuisé physiquement et
psychologiquement et que finalement ils
avaient la certitude d'être face à des
pillards qui n'obéissaient pas aux
injonctions et qu'il y avait une urgence
à évacuer le restaurant écoutez moi j'ai
pas du tout cette version après la
justice fera son travail et
naturellement mais je crois que ces
personnes étaient de simples
manifestants qui étaient allés se
réfugier dans le restaurant parce qu'on
effectivement on avait un climat
insurrectionnel
les rues étaient keller était quasiment
irrespirable c'est à dire qu'on avait du
gaz lacrymogène partout et des gens qui
étaient allés se réfugier ont été
traités comme des criminels
or moi je rappelle en ma qualité
d'ancien policiers que le seul cadre
légal qui n'autorise l'usagé de la force
c'est la légitime défense
or sur ces images je dirais que on n'a
pas le sentiment que les manifestants
sont particulièrement menaçants à
l'endroit des policiers
et si vous voulez la fatigue
psychologique physique est allé je me
fais l'avocat du diable
le fait de ne pas répondre à des
injonctions de quitter et de libérer les
lieux de quitter le restaurant et
libérer les lieux ne justifie absolument
pas au plan légal usage de la force tel
qu'il est démontré sur la vidéo
moi je crois que malheureusement
cette avancée dans quel ce calendrier
dans kate est une entourloupe
c'est à dire qu'on essaye en quelque
sorte de réhabiliter l'igpn
à l'issue des échéances électorales
pourquoi parce que quand on posera la
question au président sortant ou même
aux candidats à la présidentielle de
savoir ce qu'ils vont faire du contrôle
policier c'est là ce qu'ils vont
supprimer les gpl ou leurs efforts mais
à la fin il vous dira mais là on
regarder ces questions dans les enquêtes
ça prend du temps c'est laborieux
finalement envoyé va le 1er décembre
2018 ça a pris du temps mais ça sort et
puis pour le reste ras sciences vous des
borniers les luttes il est c
on va laisser l'igpn ans d'enquêté et
puis une fois le président élu ou réélu
ben on on aura droit aux mêmes enfumage
grèce que celui auquel ont été confronté
cinq ans durant alors justement puisque
vous l'avez évoqué à l'époque l'igpn la
police des polices avait assuré ne pas
être parvenu à identifier la totalité
des fonctionnaires impliqués
qu'est ce que ça dit de l'igpn et de son
fonctionnement actuel
aujourd'hui c'est un débat qu'on a eu
pas mal de temps ces dernières années a
pas mal de fois d'ailleurs c'est la
question de l'indépendance de l'igpn
c'est à dire que la lige et n est une
institution qui a agi sur instruction de
du dgpn donc de la direction générale de
la police nationale qui est une
direction elle même placée sous
l'autorité du ministre de l'intérieur
donc le dgpn et le mit de l'intérieur
ont un droit de regard sur les activités
de cette institution et ça ne peut pas
fonctionner on ne peut pas être à la
fois juge et partie et donc
naturellement on se retrouve face à une
difficulté qui est une difficulté de
neutralité de discernement et parfois
même de tout de bonne volonté un tout
simplement
donc ça va être l'occasion justement
pour les candidats à la présidentielle
de se positionner clairement sur la
question du contrôle externe de
l'institution police nationale au fond
on croit savoir au regard de certaines
déclarations que marine le pen ne
souhaite rien changé pour marine le pen
l'institution police nationale
institution igpn fonctionne parfaitement
tout y écouter on va laisser on va la
laisser revenir sur ses propos
on va laisser d'autres candidats
éventuellement de route de vous donner
leur point de vue sur la question
si beaucoup d'avoir réagi sur notre
antenne loi manoir ancien policier
éditorialistes aujourd'hui pour le média